j'avais une forme de responsabilité pour
mes filles et pour les autres enfants
nés comme ça de casser les
confrontations casser les clichés
raconter la réalité des choses
[Musique]
je pense que j'ai une vraie
responsabilité de d'intervenir dans pas
du tout pour que la gpa soit légalisée
je pense que aujourd'hui l'état de la
société française n'en est pas là elle
est trop fragmentée trop clivé il faut
apaiser les choses plutôt que de
l'étendre donc en revanche je pense que
ces enfants doivent être sécurisés la
loi le dit mais le dit mal donc il n'y a
pas d'ambiguïté
les parents de ces enfants doivent être
légalement leurs parents dans le cliché
principal on entende partout que les
femmes qui acceptent ce d'accompagner
des couples comme ça et porter leur
enfant
elles sont instrumentalisés michel qui
est nous apporter nos deux films et
plein d'autres considèrent que
accompagné finalement un embryon c'est
comme être une super nounou
sauf que ça se passe in utero quand
j'entends les gens de la manif pour tous
expliqué que ces pauvres enfants qui ne
savent pas qu'il faut à meyrin une mère
et un père pour pour évidemment que
c'est enfin là ils sont pas idiots et
qu'au contraire on leur doit un devoir
de vérité quand ils sont dans un couple
homoparental ils peuvent bien penser
qu'ils ne sont pas nés deux hommes donc
au contraire ils savent même beaucoup
plus tôt que les autres
la façon dont on fait les enfants quand
vous pensez que le comité national
d'éthique a rendu un rapport la semaine
dernière pour dire à quel point c'était
impossible de légaliser la gpa
ce que je peux comprendre mais sans
jamais avoir auditionné une femme
porteuse ni un enfant né de gpa
ça paraît aberrant
[Musique]
pour moi c'était impossible parce que ça
revenait à retirer un enfant et une
femme qui l'avait porté pendant neuf
mois et l'a payé pour ça donc je suis
allé aux états unis pour bien m'assurer
que cette voie là n'était pas celle que
je voulais entreprendre
puis j'ai découvert un autre monde un
monde très réfléchi très cadrées ou ce
qu'ils appellent la gpa éthique a donc
été possible non seulement sans
traumatisme mais avec une espèce de joie
d'amour de de bien-être absolu et les
gens qui parlent dans ce procès ce
d'abord sont évidemment tout ce qu'on
s'entend il ya un certain nombre de
critères
d'abord qu'il s'agit de deux femmes une
femme qui donne ses ovocytes l'autre qui
donne la possibilité de porter un
embryon celles qui portent doit avoir au
moins deux enfants
un niveau social minimum vous choisissez
la donneuse d'ovocyte dans un fichier
en revanche pour la femme porteuse
lagence vous mais en connexion avec des
gens qui ont plutôt vos profils et c'est
elle qui vous choisit ambitionner un
syndrome de couple et elle fait le choix
de celui qui a envie d'accompagner oui
c'est un coup oui c'est beaucoup
d'argent
essentiellement d'ailleurs en frais
médicaux puisque ne serait-ce que
l'accouchement que vous prenez
évidemment en charge
il coûte 20 mille dollars évidemment
pour moi ça n'a pas été un sacrifice
financier même si ça a été un coup
important mais j'ai pas dû rogner sur
mon quotidien la réalité des gens qui
ont recours à la gpa
bien souvent c'est pas des gens qui
vivent du tout dans l'opulence mais pour
qui le désir d'enfant est tellement fort
la souffrance de ne pas en avoir est
tellement insupportable que ils sont
prêts à sacrifier tous dans leur
quotidien et trouver toutes les astuces
pour pouvoir y arriver je ne suis pas
l'exemple type
contrairement à ce que peuvent penser
certains d'une famille qui a recours à
la gpa c'est pas un truc de bobos comme
on pourrait me le renvoyer dans la tête
60 % des enfants issus de gpa qui vivent
en france le sont dans des couples
hétérosexuels aussi la caricature c'est
les couples gays qui ont de l'argent et
qui font un caprice si cela c'est un
caprice 1 avec le chemin que sa
nécessité l'investissement émotionnel
que ça représente
il faudra qu on vient de me raconter de
plus près